[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a hong kong chinese action
film called project gutenberg spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
lee mann and his girlfriend yuan live in
vancouver as painters while un creates
original art lee is more interested in
replicating the paintings made by famous
painters he is very talented in his
field of work and can replicate almost
any kind of painting to every minute
detail however his work is not very
popular among the dealers and the
gallery show organizers since they
cannot display a counterfeit painting no
matter how good it is one evening lee
returns home to hear uen's manager
telling her that she should drop being
lee's co-artist if she wants to succeed
u.n in turn asks the manager to drop her
because she would never stop being lee's
partner after a lot of struggle the duo
manages to land a spot in an art show
their paintings are displayed for the
guests to see many of them love yuen's
work but are critical of lee's paintings
one guest named the artist goes as far
as to call his painting fake yuen
furiously throws her drink in his face
and asks him to go away lee follows the
man to apologize and finds out all this
was a setup made by the artist so that
they could meet in private he says he
recognizes lee's talent for counterfeit
art and praises his precision they go to
a bar and talk over a drink the artist
claims that he also loves precise
replicas and has a job for lee if he
wants to change his life after the
encounter lee goes back to the art
gallery and burns the painting that was
insulted earlier satisfied with the
decision he calls the artist the next
day and agrees to work for him when
asked what paintings he wants to be
replicated the artist shows him a
hundred dollar bill it turns out he is
planning to make bundles and bundles of
fake money that is impossible to be
recognized since they cannot just print
the money the artist is desperate to
have someone like lee on his team
initially lee refuses to do anything
illegal but upon realizing that he will
be swimming in money he takes the offer
he returns home that day and sees yuan
moving away from their home she has
decided to leave him after the stunt he
pulled at the gallery that cost her a
lot of money in the following scene lee
joins the artist and his team on a
private plane that is flying to thailand
lee still plans to return to canada and
when you went over after making some
money the team consists of a printing
plate specialist mr yam a color theory
expert and two people in charge of
security and sales the new 1996 u.s 100
bill features the duplexes version of
franklin's portrait that is enlarged by
50
which resulted in more details and lines
even if they used the commercial printer
with the highest resolution the result
will be of a different pattern and not
precise at all moreover there is a micro
print on franklin's collar on the bill
that says the united states of america a
commercial printer would never be able
to print with this precision this is
where lee comes to play because he can
paint the bill better than the printers
secondly the bills are made of
scratch-free paper that turns the black
ink of the counterfeit detection pen
into yellow this helps bank workers
separate fake from real the artist is
yet to find a way to get the scratch
papers but until then he wants lee to
work hard on the painting process for
the next few weeks lee paints the
hundred dollar bill with absolute
precision not missing a single streak or
line to embed the watermark and the
security thread in the counterfeits is
yet another difficulty for this they are
going to use a chinese painting method
where the real painting is sandwiched
between two papers that are pressed to
make the middle layer stand out next
comes the printing process that is under
mr yam he uses his expertise to make a
printing plate that paints within ten
thousandth of a millimeter precision on
a test round they see that there is no
more effect which means they are
successful after that the artist
discovers a way to acquire scratch paper
that is the main raw material for
production they travel to eastern europe
to a phone book manufacturing company it
turns out they use scratch paper that is
triple the width of a 100 bill to
manufacture phone books the width is
perfect for the sandwiching process so
they buy a huge batch of it disguised as
a chinese comic book company after
importing the paper to their hideout it
doesn't take them long before making the
counterfeits that look identical to real
bills they sell it through an antique
shop to wholesalers and are very careful
about the people they do business with
after six months of working with the
artist lee returns to vancouver to
return a key to un he refuses to meet
her and decides to leave the key on her
desk the artist thinks he's a coward for
giving up so easily which causes an
argument between the two to prove his
bravery the artist brings out a gun and
goes to a police car to conduct a
robbery out of nowhere that's not
bravery that's idiocy lee has to
reluctantly help him in it but he cannot
shoot anyone out of fear by the end of
the impromptu robbery all the policemen
are dead and lee is left shocked he
finally realizes his boss is not a sane
person moreover he only signed up to
paint not to kill people then we are
introduced to a counterfeit bill expert
in the police named wing he is called to
hong kong from canada because the police
have gotten a hint of a sudden rise in
fake dollar bills all around the world
wing meets the head of hong kong police
inspector ho they go on an undercover
mission and poses customers who are
willing to buy fake money after several
meetings with a lot of brokers they are
allowed to meet the artist at a boat
party however their hopes to catch the
culprit are crushed when they find out
the painter sent his brokers in his
place they test wing in several ways and
figure out that he is not a threat one
afternoon lee approaches the artist and
claims that he doesn't want to be on the
team anymore still he promises to find a
new way for them to keep their business
going before his departure the artist
allows him to do whatever he wants
without a fuss in the following montage
we see the team traveling the world and
selling their money at an international
level the profits are insane and so is
the demand for their goods then they get
the highest bid from the thai crime boss
the general he calls the artist and his
team to his hideout for a business
meeting but it turns out that the
general killed the artist's father long
ago hence the artist is here not for
business but to kill the general he asks
lee to trigger the explosives in his
jacket but a cowardly lee refuses
seconds later a car explodes and a
shootout ensues everyone from the
general's team is killed except for
their counterfeit money expert named
sarah she is about to die after catching
on fire but is saved by lee after the
group departs she is taken care of and
invited to the team because of her
expertise lee takes care of her and the
two develop a friendship meanwhile the
artist gives her a fake id under the
name u.n after lee's ex-girlfriend the
team takes a one-year break from
business after the incident during this
time lee and the artist go back to
vancouver to meet you in and win her
over by now she has turned into a famous
artist selling hundreds of her paintings
however things go downhill when they
find out she is engaged to her manager
the artist wants lee to fight for his
love but he has already given up in the
following scene they are on a yacht on
their way to a business meeting with the
undercover policeman wing the artist
does his own research about the customer
and finds out about his true identity he
also discovers the police were able to
find them because the printing plane
expert mr yam broke the rules and bought
a watch with counterfeit money as they
had decided his family will now have to
be killed for his mistake mr yam begs
for his family's life but the artist
shoots him dead lee tries to retaliate
but is knocked out after that the team
meets wing who is unaware that they know
his true identity once they are in a
closed room the artist asks lee to kill
wang but he refuses in the end he has to
do the job himself to make league get
over his fear of killing the artist has
kidnapped u.n and her fiance he hands
lee a gun and asks him to kill them
since it will be easier for him to kill
people he hates however lee refuses yet
again in a fit of rage the artist kills
yuen's fiancee himself while lee saves
yuan sarah knows that lee will also be
killed after this she remembers that he
saved her life long ago and attacks the
rest of the team in the ensuing shootout
all the members die and lee finally
kills the artist sarah makes him let go
of um and brings him to a resort that
the artist had bought for them they find
out he is still alive because the police
never recovered his body one day lee
discovers that u.n is about to organize
a memorial for her late fiance he
suspects the artist will be there to
kill her to get to him despite sarah
begging him not to go he does it anyway
however on the way he accidentally uses
the counterfeit money and is apprehended
by the police he is then taken to hong
kong under inspector ho's custody and
interrogated lee is terrified of getting
killed by the artist if he reveals his
identity hence he keeps quiet about
everything a few days later u.n comes to
meet him and convinces him to help the
police they settle on an agreement that
lee will be released into witness
protection for revealing the artist's
identity and criminal history after that
lee starts telling the police all about
his past starting from his relationship
with u.n how he met the artist the
money-making process the time he
witnessed the first murder and so on
after he reveals everything he also
helps the police make sketches of the
only two remaining people from their
team sarah and the artist by the end of
the day lee and yuen are left in a hotel
with security outside the police
immediately start a search for the
artist now that they have a picture of
him while they are at it inspector ho
notices him disguised as a police
officer in the police headquarters
itself she and her team arrest him and
hold him down only to find out the man
has been a policeman for several years
and couldn't be the artist at all this
is especially strange because he was the
one playing the role of the artist from
the very beginning it is then revealed
that the policeman was the guy who
helped ho to bring lee from thailand to
hong kong lee had seen his face on the
route and remembered it a flashback
shows us that lee and the artist are the
same person lee created the artist in
his mind to escape the reality that he
is a horrible person every time he was
fearful of the crimes the artist was
committing lee was the one committing
them he was also the one who killed mr
yam and his family for buying a watch in
the last shootout that killed most of
his team he was the one who killed
yuen's fiance and the shootout was
caused due to a conflict among them yet
another shocker comes when we realize
the girl who came to bail lee out is not
u.n but sarah she was so obsessed with
lee that she got plastic surgery since
her face was burnt after the surgery she
looked identical to un she came to save
her lover and the two have already fled
from the hotel room after killing the
guards in the following scene we see the
couple together in bed sarah is sad that
she is always going to be a counterfeit
u.n and a second option for lee when
asked if he sees her for herself lee
doesn't try to hide that he is still in
love with the real u.n the next day they
get on a boat and run away from hong
kong but on the way sarah reveals she
has been driving in circles for hours
and they are still in hong kong's
territory she wants to kill him and
herself and end this life of misery they
are soon surrounded by the police but
before they can catch them the boat
explodes killing both of them in the
process in the last scene inspector ho
goes to the real yuan to inform her that
her fiance's killer has died on looking
at a picture of lee she recognizes him
as just a neighbor she had long ago it
turns out lee even fantasized his entire
relationship with euhan and they were
never together
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching